Ok, with the loss of the cones that
detect red light, and the resulting protanopia, or red
green color blindness that we talked about in our
comparison up here. We would probably expect to have
trouble at stoplights that have red yellow green
to signify them. Electrical wires where there's red, green,
and yellow to have to distinguish. A red and
green apple, a Braeburn versus a Granny Smith apple.
But we shouldn't have trouble distinguishing a blue from a
yellow paint. Now obviously in reality, there are context clues to
help people with red green color blindness distinguish what they
need to. For example, when you look at the stoplight, you
don't have to be able to distinguish the colors off
that well because there's particular order to the colors. Or even
looking at the apples for example, there's differences in their size
and texture, they give you clues. The electrical wires might actually
be a genuinely difficult situation for someone to find themselves in.
Or the case of paint colors or of different colored clothing.